his reaction in it he didn't mean to
like i saw a student but he didn't know
what else to do yeah yeah
he just came out was like and then like
he you could tell he he came with the
back right
he had to have to let go he had to let
go
he felt like he was like
[Music]
loving you
is easy cause you're beautiful
i think it's deleted and everything that
i do is filled with
loving you
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
welcome guys thank you for joining me
and um flakes
on this luscious
glorious monday
sunday if you're a patron gang ten pound
patron anyway
afternoon you know the vibes my name
as they call him is jimmy j let him know
and i'm with
my um colleague and friend compadre you
know the vibes it's your boy
fuego aka fujad ak mr lava lover man
miss aka mr steal your girl
you know the vibes you know editing set
we're just going to go straight into it
guys
patreon i'm going to do on a asm asm i
can't ever say the thing probably
because you say for me because
asthma asthma we're going on an
asthmatic asthmatic
asmr asmr
guys patreons
don't worry about that guys don't worry
about it so guys yeah patreon you know
the vipes it's um
three pound a month 10p a day running my
p
mum it's not it's not hard yeah we've
been doing this for a while now
we're tired you feel me we're tired
we've been doing this for a long time we
appreciate the help so far
but we need more help we need more help
we need more help
need all the help you can muster what is
it
goku spirit bomb family do you remember
that he stands there for three episodes
three episodes just gathering all the
particles from the trees the birds the
flowers
everything every organism that lives
we've been holding this spirit bomb for
for months for months now over a year
we've been holding the spirit bomb
and some of you man are still under it's
about this big
this is this is it's as small as a
resident frieza will swallow that so
small as a resin gun guys come on
come on guys come on now you can do
better you're doing fantastic but you
can do you can do this a little bit
better so tell a friend to tell a friend
to tell a friend
help us to help you if your mom's
chilling there and she's not
subscribed you're just like mom what's
three pound to you what is really
literally go up to your
mom quick question quick what's three
pound to you she'll be like what what's
what's what what's three pound a month
to you nothing
exactly sign up today mom how much is
your gym cost that you haven't been to
in six months
boom bang 20 pound a month yeah run me
free
because the boys need it spirit bomb is
hanging it's fun it's hanging
and chilling so obviously if you like
like if you want to comment comment uh
have a little conversation guys
get involved we like to stay active jump
on the instagram get involved
twitter subscribe to the luscious audio
crispy in your eardrums um eargasms
every monday
you know the vibes um and without
further ado
introduction done and i want to learn
so um a lot of people might know this
one already but did you know that
the um logo for twitter the bird was
named after larry larry bird that played
for the celtics
oh they just called it larry they called
it larry because the co-owner of twitter
was a huge celtics fan
back in the day wow so he called it
larry after larry bird
didn't know that now you know guys swear
down that's a quick and easy fun that is
a quickie i don't know what the [ __ ] to
say about that quick and easy okay so it
is a quick and easy fun fact fair play
you learn something new every day it's
random is what we're here for guys yeah
man there you go
um in that case i'll jump straight into
the fan theory
hit me this one again is it's dark and
juicy
it's dark and juicy let me find it for
you but um
it is so this one's about rugrats so
again you think it's light-hearted
it's not so theory about rugrats
yeah that none of the babies exist
excuse me and they're all figments of
angelica's imagination
nah nah i'll run it nah
right so this uh rugrats fan theory
states
that all the babies were merely a
product of a lonely girl's imagination
angelica imagined her parents friends
having babies
in order for her to have someone to play
with because she's the only child in it
and her parents she always has that doll
in it yeah um
what a doll's name what's it called like
it's called with the
the hair yeah yeah yeah yeah he's gonna
say i was gonna say it was malibu stacy
but that's simpsons in it
oh it's called um keep reading the thing
now i wanna remember it fam
you won't before i type in angelica's
doll
tell me what begins with uh hold on let
me type in angelico's doll
name c
c celia no close though
oh cecilia close it's not cecilia
well no because i said close who is it
cynthia
that's the one center shut the [ __ ] up
read the sigma so right yeah start again
sorry so
this row rats fan theory is pretty
creepy it states that all the babies
were merely a product of a lonely girl's
imagination
yeah angelica imagined that her parents
friends had babies in order for her to
have someone to play with
yeah chucky and his mother actually died
which is why his father is constantly a
nervous wreck
tommy was a stillborn leading stu
his dad to always make toys in the
basement for the son he never had
and the devilles had an abortion
so angelica imagined a male and a female
twin
as she didn't know the gender
fam that's very very very dark
super dark that's very dark for a kid's
show very dark
makes sense though the thing is
i don't necessarily remember the
background story of
the parents too well for me to know that
that makes sense
well the the the dad uh tommy's dad was
always making toys
i think he went either way for a toy
factory or like an advertisement firm or
something
he's always making toys and he was
coming up with these loopy concepts
for new toys um
and i'm pretty sure
uh you've got phil and lil's mum yeah
who's like this tomboy yeah
um and she's always doing like weird
fitness [ __ ]
um yeah i do remember her doing fitness
yeah
the mom died i don't remember chuckie
doesn't have a mom it's just him and his
dad
and his uh dad's office is ginger guy
with the mustache
and he's nervous nervous like chucky
he's always a nervous wreck
okay uh and that's pretty much all of
them yeah and then you've got angelica's
mum and dad who just work all the time
yeah
and that's why she's a spoiled [ __ ] and
she's a learning child she just gets
toys
damn but she has no friends damn and
even the black girl's not really her
friend that's her age isn't it
the black girl that comes around and
plays with the kids she's not dead she
doesn't [ __ ] with angelica like that
whoever thought of that has got a weird
mind but interesting that is very
interesting but also very they need to
pick up a script and then start writing
that's tough they can take so they can
go somewhere with that
that is very tapped um it's super tabbed
yeah it's [ __ ]
um but before i go into the woods rava
yeah i've got an interest
i'm not interesting topic but um it
reminded me when i was thinking about
angelico and just being a sport [ __ ]
do you remember do you remember like
school bully times when you were a kid
yeah do you remember like any specific
school bullets
i know you said you weren't bullied
personally but do you remember any
specific school bullies
uh yes yes i do
i'm trying to think of a sp i can't
remember specific examples because this
guy wasn't in my
um he was in my year but he wasn't in
any of my classes and he wasn't in my
form
um i remember his name till day but i
won't be out because people that
obviously people that i went to
secondary school with
know this guy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all i'm going to say is an albanian
brother
albanian as an albanian brother swear
down yeah yeah he sounds wham
he already thinks the thing is he wasn't
wham like if i see him now i probably
won't think he's one yeah but for my
stature back then
he was not necessarily he was the
biggest guy about but he had them
he had basically like the most clout in
terms of people knew about him and you
didn't want to be on the wrong side of
him
oh okay it could be a situation where
like all right you're talking [ __ ] yeah
all right i'mma call x y and z
and okay them ones them ones
it was one of the ones where he's always
sagging everything was pissed
he had a bandana but you he just wasn't
he sounds like the biggest waste man
i've ever met but bro he
he you you think that now because you
can imagine that now as a 30 year old
yeah
yeah yeah yeah when you're 16. oh yeah
i'm petrified of course
i was petrified oh of course but i never
because like i said i wasn't in any of
these classes or anything i only saw him
out in the school
like we never really interacted because
i had no reason to interact with him
like the people some of the people that
i was in my form with or had other
lessons with
weighing the classes for other things
yeah yeah yeah i knew him through that
yeah so just one of them ones but i just
knew he bullied the life out of people
i saw it i just saw it doing what for
them i don't the thing is i don't know
it was one of them ones where he
probably got a kick out of it i was
probably one of those ones where because
everyone because he knew a lot of people
feared him
he it was just his day-to-day
recreational activity thing to do it
wasn't even like a thing where
uh someone someone did something to her
someone stepped tony sure said that's
why i retaliate he was just he was just
an [ __ ]
yeah he's just an [ __ ] to people
especially people younger people be like
so younger people as well
that's low it was just an [ __ ] yeah
just how it was but like nothing that i
can be like oh he did this this because
i never really saw like
the beginning to end of anything because
i wasn't like i said i wasn't he's boy
or anything
yeah yeah yeah yeah in the school yeah
but i remember him until
i see his face so i can see his face
here i can see
there's when i moved up north
i actually don't remember any specific
bullies
but when i lived in luton the secondary
school i went to loot and i was just
there for year seven
but there was one don he was actually in
my form
yeah and in my classes he was a bully
family he was just a
bully he has seven in year seven oh wow
fam
but it wasn't even like a rummy rummy p
or do this for me or do that for me he
just liked to be aggressively
like horrible to people like not even
with words just like
he had pent up aggression he wanted to
fight people for all the time
and he would want he wanted to
get you to the point where you had to
fight him do you know what i mean he was
a bully like that
yeah and um his name was mark i don't
give a [ __ ] about baiting his name out
because
that was year seven and he was on the
other side of the [ __ ] country now i
don't care
um his name was mark yeah and i remember
he had a dead tooth
mm-hmm and seven in year seven he had a
dead tooth so i don't know what happened
to him
he might go probably got cracked by his
dad which is why he's [ __ ] so angry
at the time
he had a hundred percent a gray tooth
here and his name was mark and boy
i remember he would antagonize people
hmm
antagonize people and then one day so
basically yeah listen
he got me one day and i had to i nearly
bit a hole in my tongue
not to smack this you up but you know
when um something happens to you but you
need to keep
composure so much yeah found yeah
do you remember when you were younger
and you'd bump your head against
something and you'd get a massive bump
if you smacked it hard enough yeah it
doesn't really happen too much
as an adult unless you get tamped up
yeah but i remember one time i'm walking
between classes
my man must have ran up behind me and
pushed me somewhere
your neck would have found i was walking
he pushed me like that and i was like
cool man i already know who it is
i already know who this guy is he's like
james james what are you gonna do push
me back
and i was like nah i'm not about it like
leave it leave it yeah you don't believe
it leave it i'm thinking i'm not about
to be this tom's victim
yeah because i'll cut a man
to make a boyfriend yeah i was thinking
i'm not about
that yeah i don't want to because i'm in
my head i'm so petrified of taking it
too far
yeah not even that i've got angry she's
not where you mean i know what you mean
in front of the whole school i was
trying to move to the tingle emily as
well
and she was in that class and i was
thinking you know what
yeah involved because it's only gonna go
two ways
yeah i'm even gonna retaliate
yeah and like what if i retaliate it's
only gonna go two ways i'm either gonna
retaliate
and get the [ __ ] kicked out of me i
didn't think that was gonna happen but
you never know i mean year seven yeah i
don't have that much combat experience
yeah anything's possible experience no
man's hit puberty yeah but all the same
kind of thing in it yeah no one's got
fighting experience like that and he's
probably got more than me
because he's always out to scrap yeah
and certain i don't know what happened
to that too
but i don't want to know i don't know
what you learned from that
so man dash me and i was like all right
leave him whatever whatever i just
laughed
off kind of thing fam he grabbed
my um school back and started spinning
he grabbed it were your feet off the
floor no no no
are you sure yes they were
[Laughter]
a man spun you around in year seven you
know
i can see it now in the hallway i'm
closing my eyes and i'm picturing it
he's shut down you like it yeah finish
your story because i already know what
happened
i already know what happened he spun you
and dashed you from
he grabbed my bag yeah and he spun my
obviously my wallabies crumbled
and i fell yeah i bought my head on the
wall
oh and even then fam i tried to get up
and give it one of
them brush off things and i was just
like
i told him big man trust me i saw i gave
him like the
the my gear cue sharon come on look here
as a big man trust me don't do that
again yeah
trust me i'm gonna lock it now yeah
trust me don't do that again
and he was like nah i'm actually sorry
because i was thinking now
you've pushed me to the point where i
can't return so i'm trying to keep it
cool when emily's here and she's like
oh james you're right and i'm like oh
calm fam yeah she's like are you sure
fam
unbeknownst to me take your umbrellas to
me i had the bump off the sentry on my
head
yeah it was out here oh and i'm just
sitting there straight face with this
massive [ __ ] bump on my head
and everyone's like you're right you're
right and i'm thinking this might think
he had me up i
had no idea what i was going to do i
think he had me up i'm fine
i'm fine the thing is throbbing fam and
it seems massive
until my boy rhys had to come up to me
that big man between me and you
you've got a massive bump in your head
you need to see the nurse
like it's huge and that's what i gave it
one of them
the the gentle one like the permitting
the bruno mars
i had to give it just the light one and
i was like oh nah
nah nah fam mould conquest they sent me
home for the day
the nurse took one look and ran my
she mom one look around my mom and i was
thinking luckily it was a friday
so i had the weekend to heal and cool
off yeah yeah yeah oh but i was ready to
scrap but
the thing with my man is he got his
comeuppance one day yeah
we had a kid in our class called zeeshan
yeah one pakistani don
my mum was just he was so mellow you
know he reminds me of
he reminds me of um kevin from the
office
yes the big thing yes yes so he was
nobody was fat and nowhere you're stupid
but he was
chill [ __ ] he didn't want to hammer fly
he was just
big tall like tall and overweight
and just like didn't want just minding
himself super polite
really well spoken just soft as a
butterfly fan yeah and um
one day mark just just turned to z
shannon's thought this is today's target
because
this is today's target so i turned to my
man
and i can't remember what he was doing
but he was talking smack and just
getting rough with it
as he said ah no stop stop stop stop
stop i'm not bad
and then man shut up sharp sharp and i
just i can't remember if he was
i think he was probably trying to give
him a dead arm okay i was like oh let me
give you that arm is that no no no
let me give you that a minute let's see
if you can handle it it's like no no i
don't want to do it but
and is that cool whack see i was like no
i don't do that i did that hurt did i
hurt you i'm dead and he's like nah nah
it's not dead it's fine it's all right
calm
whack fam my heart's starting to pump
for my man
where was this in the classroom this was
in a uh no this was
in a weird place like at the bottom of
the stairs like
just before you know when you go uh so
you go down the stairs in a school block
and then you go through a double doors
and there's a hallway there yeah yeah
yeah but there's like a weird little
area at the bottom of the stairs
i know exactly what you mean so it's
just like people congregate yeah
yeah yeah it was one of them okay okay
okay and um he's just chilling there
whack wait he must have bought my three
four digs and then just like that big
man
don't do it again that his voice dropped
then yeah
and you can start to see his size now
his his shoulders are flexed now
and i said don't do it again and mark's
thinking all right man's
the the the prey is standing up to man i
can't have that
somebody's audience he's got audience
now man said shut up
yeah gave him a whack whack fam a whack
whack on his arm and said is your arm
dead yet
fam zushan stood up said that i want you
he was sitting down this whole time he
was sitting down the whole time he stood
up said he warned you grabbed him here
ty and all grabbed him here
he grabbed him here mark was here
he pulled him mark was here yeah he
picked up his lunchbox plastic lunchbox
i think it was aladdin or something
and clawed him in his head and just
wiped the [ __ ]
out of him from the apples came out
sandwiched by everything man was just
clapping the [ __ ] out of him
and he said mark was dangling
mark was dangling fam let go of him
dropped to his knees
i couldn't believe my eyes i couldn't
believe my eyes the whole school would
have cheered that day
the whole school was gassed gasped knock
the [ __ ] out
this show must have gone [ __ ] that
night
man beat the scene you beat the school
bully mango
that's the first time i realized like
size actually matters
because then times you think just
personality matters isn't it yeah yeah
you think like
if i act tough i'm tough stuff you know
what i mean and no one wants to
[ __ ] with that because no no your
reputation
it's all about reputation in school
before anyone hits puberty it's
reputation
so when you've got kids that just happen
to be bigger you don't assume they're
any stronger than anyone else
and because they're never that when
they're actually bigger
as kids they're usually clumsier they're
not athletically gifted at that time do
you know what i mean
it's only when you're in year 9 10 11
when you're
progressing faster than everyone else
that you're actually better at athletics
yeah you're stronger and you're faster
than everyone else and that's when
people don't want to [ __ ] with you then
yeah
but when you're a big kid who hasn't
even hit puberty yet you're just
called fat yeah yeah i mean and you're
just like you're just whatever fam
zig zag proved me wrong that day grip
stock mark clumped his head off
and left him for dead did you see that
aftermath like what did mark do
mark just picked himself i think he was
crying
but you know when your eyes are
bloodshot red you don't want it you
don't want to let the drop fall yeah so
it's just there
so i'm just there just veins just i can
imagine his neck
full of veins ah he went home and caught
himself
that night oh i couldn't come to school
the next day
i don't think he wanted to he can never
be the bully again yeah
i don't remember him bullying anyone
after that his reputation is done
it was done from that day and i remember
thinking ra boy
zeesham's the most gentle guy gentle
giant you can't [ __ ] with people like
that
because that will snap i couldn't
believe man was sitting down at first if
i'm sitting down firming it
damn is your arm down and giving the one
two gave him the bang bang
is it dead yet you [ __ ] [ __ ] is it
dead
this man's family his neck was here that
would have sweetened me
no one could grab me up like that no one
could grab me out of that i will grab
his wrist
i will do anything to get away i i'll
kick him get off me i'll be shaking my
chores for the lunchbox fan
he snapped his lunchbox off of that i
don't even think he picked it up
afterwards
he cracked his head open and just left
everything left all the evidence
it was too much probably that's so funny
i was thinking you're [ __ ] i don't
know
i've seen i would love to have seen big
man
getting bullied i would love to have
seen that he bodied him
oh he's just redemption for every
redemption for everyone
that's amazing that's amazing it was too
much
you could tell afterwards he just wanted
to be like
what now one of them ones you think you
can do this to me
jay jay
i'm putting cases on all you [ __ ]
my god uh quick scenario obviously you
said um
uh when my man grips to you and then
dashed you and you got the thing on your
head right yeah
and obviously he said um your mom got
called you had to go home the same that
same day
scenario what if that happened to your
son what are you gonna do
you get caught with saying oh my boys
your boy has been
involved in a a scuffle he's got a
massive bruise on his head you need to
come and pick him up
what are you doing
i don't know i really don't know because
it's like
you know those premeditated violence
things that we spoke about yeah
i'd want to be like obviously i'm not
out here trying to put my hands on kids
yeah and i'd like to say i'm the i'm
i'll be the dad that's like yo
son get your [ __ ] yeah let's go
yeah if school's over or whatever let's
go to his job where the [ __ ] does this
guy live
let's get out you you and him are gonna
settle this like men do you know what i
mean
that's what i want to be yeah yeah yeah
front yard you might have got to settle
this like men
and it says dad tries it yeah
his dad's gonna have to sit on the
doorstep and watch it's the range of the
scene from f is for family when
um have you seen the whole thing yeah
yeah when all the family are fighting
i think it's who's the who's um my man's
bully
oh god i can't remember his name came
back yeah and
him and his dad were fighting the whole
of frank's family yeah outside the yard
yeah
yeah yeah i'd want to be like yo
have him up have him upset all this like
men let's go
get that frustration out that's what i
want to be like but i would
for one i would hate to put my son in
that situation if that's not the kind of
guy he is of course you know what i mean
and he's scared
yeah and he's thinking i don't want to
do this bro like i just want to
run away but the last thing i want to do
is have to like have a [ __ ] fight
with this guy
from to what tap me up again yeah like
nah that's what i'd hate
and i'd also hate if my son was on it
like yeah [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] this guy let's go for me to go to
his yard and see the youth come out
scared
i would hate that just have big man up
in his yard talking to his dad i get
your [ __ ] son out here
so my son's going to smack him up for
his dad to be scared
and for his son to come out like dad
we don't want it we don't want it like
no man
and to just everyone to be shook and to
see a little kid's face
scared yeah to think he's going to get
this [ __ ] kicked out of him for a
mistake he made at school
that's like you know that premeditating
by the time i've driven over there yeah
i haven't got it in me as much anymore
and for to see that i'll be like what am
i doing man
what am i doing what is this even going
to resolve so
i don't know what i do i'll be angry
bruv but like
no one i always remember
i always remember there was one time
because everyone likes to think there'd
be the parent that
is willing to run up in the school like
who's putting paws on my kid
i will smack you up i'll smite the
teachers up by smart the parents up
everyone wants
to be that dad yeah but it does more
harm than good
of course because i remember there was
one time i was playing out with all my
boys
and there was a girl i thought she was
fine i thought she was [ __ ] peng
yeah but i don't think many people
agreed okay
because she was getting abused by the
other [ __ ]
i think she had a bit of acne okay but
she was like mixed race like half
chinese half black
oh and light skinned as well i remember
from earlier i was thinking that's a mix
that's a mix
from early no one was acknowledging it
yeah yeah i don't think asians were in
back there but i could see it yeah
this [ __ ] is fine yeah and then she was
getting abused from the yachts
and then i remember she went home crying
10 minutes later
her dad pulls up with her gets her out
of the car
and rallies us all up and said who the
[ __ ] was bullying my daughter
who the [ __ ] was it like come forward if
you want to chat chat now in it come
forward
and the only any obviously no everyone
was scared no i said nothing
and he left off vex and i remember
thinking
that's so embarrassing for her
yeah she's gotta face us again tomorrow
yeah that's so embarrassing
because all that's going to happen is
you mana
everyone's just going to be like oh you
have to get your dad yeah he's going to
get dad like it's just going to keep
happening yeah
and it was just like ra like watching
the dad do it i remember thinking
[ __ ] that's embarrassing yeah i can see
why he's doing it
but he's making matters worse bruh yeah
but sometimes you can't think
you don't when you're angry like that
you don't think and especially when your
kids involved you don't [ __ ] think
you want to kick the [ __ ] out of
everyone yeah but to us yeah fam
if i get the caller your son just got
bodied up in the playground
he's barling there's a bump on his head
size of a golf ball you need to come
i don't know what i do i don't know what
i do bro i really don't know
because i remember when um prime example
i don't know if i've said this on here
before
but i got my bike stolen when i was a
kid i don't think you've said this on
here
it was when i just moved up to uh up
north yeah
same year same year seven summer of year
seven
uh bought my i was playing out with my
boys i bought my bike out
they were like i want to go for a bike
ride yeah bought my bike up
and one don that was in year 11 while
i'm in year 7 we could see him
all the way down the bottom of the field
from where we are yeah
and then i mean all my boys had our
bikes he said my boy turned to me kyo
you know
yeah talk to me all right listen he's
going to ask to borrow your bike yeah
say no yeah say no i'm like yeah i say
no i say no he's like now trust me
say no yeah yeah and i was like calm
down i'll say no
yeah and he's like cool fam
he rolled up to everyone and it's like
yo let me take you by to shop real quick
here now i'm going home in a minute all
right cool
john let me borrow your bike i'm going
shop hey joe's like no no no you can't
have my bike bruh it's not even mine
it's
my
brother's is that cool you me
new boy he called me new boy new boy let
me borrow your bike and i was like nah
nah nah who's that
big man let me borrow your bike honestly
i went prepared for the second question
and then he got body with it yeah yeah
and he was like big man i'll be right
back why would you not let me buy your
bike yeah and i didn't have an excuse
yeah and he's looking me like
family looking like a blind blank family
i warned you
don't let him borrow the bike yeah fam i
was like oh broth
you can't borrow a bike man he's like
why i wasn't i didn't have a word yeah
he's like you're going home too
yeah come on i'm just going to show
people back in two minutes yeah
and i was like uh fine like i i
i have no out now and obviously i'm not
gonna be like nah [ __ ] off bro
you're not having my bike because he'll
just kick me off it yeah so i was like
all right man he went sharp kia turned
to me he said big man that bike is not
coming back and i was thinking
this is real life i mean
he's gonna bring the bike back this is
real life
come on man what is this boy's in the
hood he's gonna bring the bag back
[Laughter]
boy he's in the hood oh he's gonna bring
it back chill
like chill fam ten minutes passed
half an hour past i'm seeing the sunset
my mom said be back by the time the
lights turn on
i'm thinking where's my bike cars went
to the shop
went everywhere gone
kia said brother i warned you i told you
not to give him that bike
i was like [ __ ] fam walked home
first thing my mom said when i got in
here where the [ __ ] is your bike
how's that one guy took it in here and
she was like what the [ __ ] happened
big man obviously she got vexed at me in
it yeah she he's like he said he wanted
to buy my bike so i wish
to go shopping and i just landed why
would you not borrow your bike yeah i
want to play [ __ ]
you ain't seen this guy he's in year 11.
i don't have i don't have a leg to stand
on he's if i give him a bike where he
takes it yeah
he's your choice
fam so we go for it my mom [ __ ]
grounded me
yeah um she um
i won't say his name all right but um
she picked me up
got me in the car the next day roll
around uh my the area that i play out in
grilled all my embarrassment in front of
all my friends where's my man's house
where's my man's house where's my man's
house
[ __ ] sake man mom just leave it bro
the bike's gone let's just leave it yeah
i don't need the bike so where is it
where is it all my boys i don't know i
don't know i don't know i don't know
just embarrassing me and then i'll see
you [ __ ] sake
drove me home whatever cuss me out and
then um
i go to school next day come home in the
kitchen my bike sit in there
and my dad's sitting there with a grin
in his face and i'm like
what the [ __ ] yeah and man's like i've
got your bike back
yeah and i was like how yeah man said he
went to my school
this is how you know date of protection
was not a thing when we're in school bro
oh my god he said he went to my school
went to the reception explained the
situation and said
this uh bruh in year 11 this is his name
um he had a very unique first name so
they didn't need his last name yeah yeah
yeah
this is his name um he stole my son's
bike
i want his i want his address so i can
get it back the reception just gave him
it
mad fam mad fat
these days you'll lose your job fam
you're giving out a child's address to a
strange black man
mad fam anyway gave him the address
he went to donny's yard and said
obviously run it run the bike now
was who opened the door the the mum oh
man that mom opened the door and said
your son stole my son's bike
get it
imagine opening the door and hearing
that rattled apparently she smacked him
up
to get that [ __ ] bike now so he
obviously just
got the bike and it's so funny to think
that
at that time because even thinking back
then he's so
big yeah like the guy that told my bike
he's so big thinking back then
but then i imagine how he looked to my
stepdad yeah
i said i must have thought he was a
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah so he went and
got the bike
gave it to myself mostly i said that boy
at home and the first as soon as he said
i went to my mansion and got it back for
you
i was thinking what have you done you're
going to be dead tomorrow
you can't show my face in the canteen
what do you mean
the very next day fam i'm eating my ham
and cheese sandwich
donnie rocks up like rawr got your dad
to come to my house yeah
well you can't fight for yourself nah
fam this thing
oh well i'm just trying to eat and you
know you're trying not to acknowledge
and i'm like he's not my dad he's my
stepdad like that means [ __ ]
that makes my house worse that made
everything worse
and that went on for years when i say
years
i'm saying my man had left college
had got a job at the [ __ ] corner shop
every time he bumps into me where's your
stepdad bruv where's your step though
really it was just that bad and i was
thinking first of all get a life
and second of all like come on man
but yeah that went on for years and i
was just like jesus christ and it's one
of them things it's like
he was doing nothing but looking out for
me yeah but at the same time he just
[ __ ] and ruined it i would have rather
just not had the bike ever again
ruin the kid's life oh bro but yeah to
to your point fam i don't know what
would you do
i've completely forgotten a question to
be honest i know i'd always do this i'm
sorry oh my no
um thinking about it in hindsight
there's only so much i could do because
i wouldn't want to be the one to
obviously want him um inadvertently
embarrass my kid in school
obviously i'll be doing it from a place
of anger and love for my child but yeah
yeah it wouldn't it wouldn't bode well
for him or her at the end of the day
so i actually don't know what i'll do
unless i'm in that situation but what i
would like to do
is [ __ ] find a parent's yard find the
kid's yard and find their parents and
speak to the [ __ ] person probably top
up their parents i'll be so angry oh
but that in a realistic world that
probably wouldn't happen so yeah
i don't know i don't know it's a tough
one it is tough because
i wouldn't i've never been in a
situation where my parents have had to
come and address the situation that's
happened to me
but i can only imagine how humiliating
it will be oh 100
so i wouldn't want to put my kids
through that so i don't know man
there's no right answer there is no
right answer you kind of just want him
to leave it and get on with it but i
don't want to teach my kid like
something you lose something like yeah i
know i know i know but i'd probably i'd
have to get my kid to start like
bro my kids are going to be fighting
from early from jump
from early because i'm not i don't want
them to ever be in that situation yeah
just like it's not nice i don't want
them to be
so comfortable with the fact that they
will [ __ ] anyone up that they don't
need to flaunt it but if the situation
ever arrives
they can just slap a man and just be
like trust me you don't want this smoke
today spin your jaw cuz
i'll spin your jaw breathe man you don't
want it today i promise you
oh and then that they just live an easy
life that's that's my dream
yeah but who knows bro the playground is
a scary place
it's the deadliest place it is the
playground's a scary place it's actually
the deadliest place
it's nasty out there it's worse than
it's worse than work
100 playground playgrounds
you're scared every day you could be at
the top of the pyramid you could fall
immediately you could fall and then the
next day is wrong for you like mama
what's
the bully what was your name mark was it
monkey was that his name yeah yeah seven
grey tooth mark yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he fell from grace right now
he pushed the wrong kid and it all
the jenga just collapsed it went fast
he'd monopolized the whole playground up
until that point and he just lost
everything he wanted one too many family
put it all on black and he just lost it
oh to a lunch box you know
a disney channel launched what i would
have given
to see that i don't think you understand
jake
what i would have given to see that now
bro it was tough out there man grip
still like
grab some tie and everything lunch box
classics
are not got drapes lemons that he left
the evidence there
apples are good bro he left his
tangerine just squished
man said clean yourself up you [ __ ]
[ __ ] damn
i would have to walk off to a round of
applause oh 100 i'd have to 100 percent
everyone i didn't even everyone was
gobsmacked no one said [ __ ] i can
imagine
i can imagine i was like [ __ ] right
you know yeah
i've never seen violence like that at
that point year seven i've never seen
violence like that
where am i gonna watch violence like
that oh it was terrifying
but yeah i've never seen violence like
that
have you ever bullied anyone no have you
ever inadvertently bullied anyone
uh probably yeah probably because
in um in year in year eight to year ten
um obviously i was in border school so
there was kind of like this hierarchy
thing where
you kind of had to respect your elders
in a sense we're not necessarily like
um taking a piss out of them but if you
ask them to do something
they're kind of obliged to do it for you
um i don't see i live when you live in
the border house
it's all mixed so i was living um i was
in a dorm room
with five other people so it was a six
bed
room and it could be you could be any
years that live in there wouldn't just
be all year eights live in
this room on blah blah so it was mixed
between seven and eleven
um and more time i'd probably say to
this person oh go and do this with me or
go and do that for me and blah blah
but sometimes they will know i'm taking
a piss yeah sometimes
sometimes now you're thinking about it
thinking about it now i probably have
bullied a lot of kids
but i've not bullied
it's hard to say because i'm not
bullying them to wear that you say mark
has been bullied yeah yeah yeah
just actively going out of his way to
bully people yeah yeah
that's not i didn't do that i probably
just
asked them to do sign they try and back
chat to me and that's what my ego comes
into play
that's the difference ego in school is
yeah that's when my ego comes to
especially if i'm older than them
because that was the mentality well that
is the mentality
i don't know about now to be fair but
that was the mentality back then when i
was in boarding school there
so you and you especially if they
backtrack you in front of
my peers like my boys that when you're
eight and nine as well the fellow
upperclassmen
you can't you couldn't you could
disrespect yeah say his arms
always have to be arm's house house bro
yeah there's one time i can specifically
remember
where i'd in and when i tell the story
you're going to think
how can that possibly be inadverted
that's class
a bullying and there's no way around it
but i promise you i was unaware until it
was too late okay
so basically there was this don in our
um in our year
i'm not gonna say his name actually
because it's horrible um but
big man when i say he he hit puberty at
like four years old
and when you think back at it you think
wow my man's life must have been
troubled at home
yeah because big man bro okay
donny never had a haircut white guy
right he hit pbe
four years old he had a full current bid
in like year eight he found it was tough
what he reeked of bo and i say read from
like say he'd wait he must wear the same
school uniform
every single day without ever washing it
his hair
was like matted and clumped up bro he
was
a walking [ __ ] for lack of a better
word it clearly wasn't his fault but
when you're in school you don't know
that it's not their fault yeah
you know what i mean yeah if your
clothes think it's your fault like say
anyone washes their own clothes
so he stunk everything like that and he
used to get it from he used to get it
all the [ __ ] time
all the time bully bully bit and i never
used to say nothing to him um
because obviously i knew that was
bullying so i i i was i'm not going to
say horrible [ __ ] to this guy
he looks like he has it tough enough
yeah and he keeps himself to himself and
he just gets
abuse about the way he stinks and it's
clearly not his fault but i didn't even
then i didn't know that wasn't his
father man if he thinks he thinks
but it's whatever um and there was one
day
i sit next to my boy adam and mine goes
james watch this
man's hair's so long i bet you money he
ain't even gonna feel
me he had like you know when you pick
off your rubber you have a robin you
just like picking a bit of it
and he dashed it and it got stuck in my
man's hair and he didn't even notice
i was pissing myself these times i'm not
thinking bullying isn't it
i'm just thinking that's the funniest
thing i can possibly think of
yeah and he did it again here here fam
he he felt nothing yeah he's got so much
dense mat in his head
he felt [ __ ] i'm crying yeah now i'm
crying for him i can't breathe
yeah then he takes it to um
then he takes it to uh rubber
from rubber he just sharpened his pencil
here pencil sharpens here
he pinged that that got stuck there
the pencil sharpenings and it's going
and he's got so much [ __ ] in his hair
now
and i i'm starting to think i don't know
if this is funny
you know what i mean yeah that's a lot
of stuff in his hair then he
threw a little pen lid in his hair and
he's like come on come on so i threw a
little pendant and it got like
dart in his hand like that and i'm like
trying not to laugh
but i'm thinking this is funny yeah and
he's got so much [ __ ] sticking out his
hair
then my boy threw a pen and the pen
licked him in his head and fell to the
floor a man didn't flinch
and i'd realized he's known the whole
time that we're doing this
he just got a pen dash in his head and
did not react
he knows that we're throwing [ __ ] in his
[ __ ] hair
but this is his life yeah he
wants to be the bigger person and not
react to the [ __ ] bullying and the
boost that he's getting
and when this lesson is over he's going
to stand up
and be dignified in his walk to the
toilet to get all this [ __ ] out of his
hair
that two [ __ ] behind him have been
dashing at him for the last half an hour
and when i realized as soon as that pen
clunked off his head
and he didn't move i really i'd never
felt like a lower human in my life
i know what you mean i was like wow
yeah what the [ __ ] am i doing bro yeah
conscience came in bro my conscience
punched me in the gut i was just like
[ __ ] bro what are we doing and i turned
to my boy i was like what the [ __ ] man
like
let's stop my man was he was a [ __ ] yeah
he was just sad [ __ ] that bro and he
kept touching pencils on his head
waiting for my man to react he pulled a
mark grey tooth mark
he just started lobbing pencils at his
head waiting for him to do something
about it
no way not that he was going to beef him
if he did do something about it yeah but
he was just thinking ah he's trying to
ignore me yeah
[ __ ] that and just kept lobbing pens and
i was like stop now like
[ __ ] stop yeah like this is abuse
what was the teacher in all of this
teachers didn't give a [ __ ] my school
was back i had a i went to the
one of the worst schools imaginable fans
really the [ __ ] that used to pop up in
my school teachers didn't do nothing
really peters were ready to square up
with students i remember once he there's
one time
[Laughter]
i went to a hood school a hood school
bro i'm surprised my school didn't have
metal detectors
i heard school there was one time there
was this
there was this fight in the canteen yeah
between a brother and sister
in year 11 yeah and it looked like
attack on titan
it looked like eren versus the armored
titans
from the hole someone i remember one of
my boys went out to me
and was like dadada is fighting in the
canteen and my man was road man from
early yeah roma he had gold tooth in
year 11. oh god
he was roadman from early father and i
was thinking miami's fine yeah
i have to see it i need to see who the
victim is yeah
rolled up in there he's in there with
his sister who's he's a twin sister
both in year 11 and she's squared up
and they are just clocking each other as
you're running into the canteen
glass is smashed there's holes in the
wall these men have been going
at it oh my god the whole school is in
this canteen going nuts for this fight
it was attack on titan fam no way
and you could hear the thunder clap when
she's
bodying him yeah fam she's in there
really like elbows tucked
like a man
and then like she's backed up against
the wall man's in there like
the teacher you know when the ties wrap
around the back yeah
the teacher's up in there like stop stop
mom must have swung for the teacher
the teacher ducked out for him he had
like a box of stunts he flipped it there
i slipped it there and was just like
that i didn't like
he didn't know what else to do he threw
his reaction in it he didn't mean to
like i saw a student but he didn't know
what else to do yeah
he just came out was like and then like
he you could tell he he came with the
back right
he had to you have to let go
he felt like he was like he felt like it
was better
i don't want to lose my job over this so
he just grips him up but my man was not
having it he was road from early family
these men were fighting fighting
wow no one can stop them your sister you
know
bro no one could stop them wow the
teachers just had to sit there and watch
until they got tired and stopped
bro it was nuts and eventually they just
stopped
shook hands i didn't even show you guys
but they they gave whatever this twin
thing was
that they had said cool see at home mama
walked out vex and just
bang kicked the door it flung against
the wall and all the glass on the door
just went
and just left just left the school fam i
don't even know if he ever came back
left to school it was wow fam
my school was hood i could never be the
head teacher
we went through we recycled they had to
resign every semester
i'm not surprised they were we were in
the news constantly
wow fam we're in the news constantly one
dawn of my year killed a guy
not at school but he killed a guy
the day before sports day i remember
year nine sports day
year nine you know he was in year nine
stabbed him 14 times
my school was nuts killed are done
bro it's not funny i'm not laughing
i'm actually not laughing bro my school
was
nuts it was crazy i don't know why it
was so bad
it was crazy oh my goodness oh my
goodness
it was different it got better the older
as i was getting into like year 10 11 it
got better
but year seven eight and nine it
shouldn't have been opened
offstead put us on the the last warning
i'm not surprised
i've said what i remember do you know
when offsets come into your school
yeah and the teachers used to be like be
on your best
[ __ ] behavior yeah yeah we used to
see it as a challenge
we literally ofsted was like act up day
yeah
the week they're in is like do the worst
[ __ ] you can do
yeah we used to have just like paper
ball fights in there
just there was one time there was a
teacher with my english teacher
she got it she had she used to
straighten her hair
she must have not had a husband or
nothing because there was one scraggly
bit at her head back
that she obviously couldn't reach or
straighten she didn't have a mirror or
something
it was always draped so it was straight
yeah straight yeah drapes
so one time we cheated in english and
offset is in there offset lady in there
sitting with a
little notepad and stuff just looking
yeah and then um
one girl's talking i think um her name
was shanice right
she's talking talking talking and then
the teacher's like shanice can you be
quiet please
she's like yeah sorry i'm sorry miss she
saw she just obviously
ignored her carry on talking took him
and then my teacher was looking at
abstain like
foxy shanice can you um stop talking
she's like yeah yeah sorry
it's just looking up i said she was like
okay
so she needs darling i'm really sorry
but if you're not going to stop talking
i'm going to have to ask you to leave
the classroom
um shadi's firm
turned she she went off she looked to
the offset lady
they said she was like let's eat your
upper doll out
why acting up because she's here austin
looked up you know the classes were done
she's like why are you showing off in
front of her big man i talk every lesson
you don't say nothing
why are you trying to show off just
because offstar's here officers take
taking notes she's there the the defense
doing bits
and it's just like i have no idea what
you're talking about shoes have no idea
this is always how i conduct my lessons
please don't act up i've already asked
you if you're not going to stop talking
i'm going to ask you to leave
she's like big man make me make me she
didn't stop
shanina was brutal brutal
brutal she used to bully me for being
light-skinned she's she was brutal
she let out fire on this teacher
she's a big man making me leave
come on make me leave i dare you
come anywhere near me i'm gonna drape
that naughty piece of [ __ ] on the back
of your head
this beehive looking thing on the back
of your head i'm gonna drape it if you
put your hands on me
with your charity shop looking butters
ass you look like a witch look at your
makeup bruh
look at your teeth you look like you
belong in a dungeon bruh
she it was like 10 minutes improv
she freestyled on her for 10 minutes she
looked like you belong in a dungeon
she went off on her from head to toe
head to toe i would have felt so small
if i was the teacher bro
teacher couldn't do nothing you know
he's trying to smile but like he can't
and you try not to cry
he's a shell-shocked
absolutely shell-shocked she had to get
another teacher all right she had to go
she had to go next door and be like
um get the male teachers to just come
and buddy up he looked in himself
shinny scout yeah and she just got up
straight it was
so dread oh fam ofsted was a game for us
it was when you think back it was
pathetic uh you remember
so much specific stuff is baffling ah
memory is good
in the in context of like past tense and
like childhood stuff yeah yeah memory is
crazy family
because i i don't remember stuff like
that at all i remember like little
things here and there but
you've got stories it's like i don't
remember just the day-to-day but there's
specific
[ __ ] that i in school i just remember i
don't know why i can't
but um boy yeah my school was disgusting
but anyway um am i the [ __ ] nuts i
mean
also hey i've been watching the pod
since early like 150 subscribers going
gang i've gotten i'm at the [ __ ] i've
been with my boyfriend since august time
and this is
this is in 2020. so this is last year
she sent this so apologies
uh so i'm gonna start again hey i've
been watching the pod since early like
150 subscribers
i've gotten am i the [ __ ] i've been
i've been with my boyfriend since august
time
and we're both planning to go but we're
both planning on going to uni in
september 2021.
he brought up whether i saw us still
together then and how he's in a
relationship for the long run etc
he was really invested however i'm not
sure where i will be then regarding
where
whether my head will turn or whether
i'll like him as much as i do
or there's no punctuation for him
i'm not sure where i will be then
regarding whether my head will
turn or whether i'll like him as much as
i as he does me
let alone be able to handle the long
distance
and the unis were four hours apart am i
the answer for not
being 100 yet or for not equaling his
feelings
would it be harsh to end it this year
before we go to uni because i don't
think i can do the long distance
and i'll be wasting my time if i invest
in a relationship thank you so much and
she was like
by the way don't get me wrong i have a
love for him but i have a lot on my
plate at the moment and i wanted to live
in a moment
i'm not thinking about it in the long
run i think this is an opening shot for
me
bro same for me for me
i've never been like uh
for me this is obviously this is just
for me people disagree with me
greatly i've had this discussion with
exes before i'm not a fight for it kind
of person
if i'm not feeling it or if even an
inkling of me is just like
i think i want to do this instead i'm
not going to be with you
it's just like it should be easy for me
it should be the same as if
if i have to wake up in black i don't
know if i see myself being through house
friend next year do you know what i mean
i just don't
see it like we're not boys we're just
not
yeah i shouldn't have to think about
this it should be yeah yeah second
nature
that's how i feel about relationships i
shouldn't have to think about i don't
know bro he's he wants this for the long
term but i
i don't know it'd lock it you open the
shot case you have to lock it purely
because
well obviously explain to him why you're
locking it because
he's obviously not going to get it from
the jump he's going to be upset yes he's
going to
try and win you back yes um but don't
for for your own sake don't be like okay
we'll try we'll try
oh yeah it's only gonna it's only gonna
get worse considering you said
the unis are four hours apart there's no
point in putting yourself through that
just to please him where you know for a
fact
you want to live your life you're about
to go to uni four hours apart it's a new
it's a completely different lifestyle
when you're in uni and i'm assuming
i'd like to see her let's dick it you're
gonna get moved to and i'm gonna assume
this is the first time you're leaving
like your yard in your comfort zone so
you know it's a completely different
world man don't
be tied down especially if he's not
going to your uni
don't be tied down man just just lock it
and
he's going to understand he's going to
understand by the time he goes to uni
yeah and there's things in and around
his first year freshers here
he's going to want it he's going to want
to be singing his dick anyway so
he's going to be hurt for now but in the
long run it will do you both
well they're good man yeah and if it's
meant to be you guys will reconnect
in three years exactly because i'm
assuming you guys are from ends so
yeah man he will link you if he wants to
and then we'll go from there but that
was easy yeah
lock it off asap all right guys thank
you very much see you soon and we'll um
catch you next week